all right guys
bang bang i've got alex here what's
going on man
bang bang super excited thank you so
much
absolutely uh all right we uh we've been
meaning to do this for a while now
and uh you are known for creating the
alex token which is uh the first
personalized
crypto token uh the people listening to
this
50 of them are going to think that
that's awesome and and
um you know really exciting and cutting
edge and the other 50 percent are going
to be like oh great another [ __ ] coin
so we'll get to all that uh in a second
but let's start with just
you your background and kind of how did
you
come uh come on to crypto and get so
enthralled with it
yeah sure um so yeah and indeed like
contention is great when 50 50
uh ratio that's the best ratio to get
attention
so i get i got this right um yeah so my
background i spent zero to 18 year old
in paris uh you know high school and
everything and then
uh studied in the uk learned english for
three years business management and then
four year i tried a startup that
failed it was about like 3d printing
platform but basically my goal in life
is to be
a founder of tech companies and
optimizing for impact
and so once this has failed i realized
that i need to have the best network
possible in order to succeed in life
and then i tried to select an industry
because i was just going for 3d printing
because of serendipity i guess
but uh i chose like three technologies
that i studied for a while which is ai
crypto and uh ar and vr and like you
know
x reality and as a young person starting
their career
crypto has just the lowest varies of
entry and you know this like the
internet's created the best
entrepreneurs in the world
and so i thought you know if they were
live today i mean they are alive today
um they would choose crypto today and it
paid off so far
it's going great so i've entered
crypto last year 12 months ago and
uh i've done a lot of primitives on
ethereum
so applications in d5 dow nft and lately
my personal token alex
and i can talk about any of those uh but
it's been such a journey so far
and super excited and now like onto my
next startup
um so yeah short background got it uh
let's just dive right into uh the alex
token i think that's the one that you're
probably known
most for uh what the hell is this thing
so basically uh it's a token that
represents my community
um and it started off in march when
um basically covet happens uh i go with
my only source of income
cut off like i'm a founder i don't have
any salaries and
i am scheduled on main stage at a big
ethereum conference to talk about
personal tokens because
i've had one for a while i was known as
the only one to have it
but i've never done anything with it and
i thought you know what
this is now and ever do a small token
sale
of twenty thousand dollars and announce
it on stage and it got great feedback
and then a month later um i released the
documents to participate in the sale 30
people did
and that's it in two days it got sold
off
and that's where i got a bit of media
attention
and it's awesome because i will be
giving 15
of my income in the next three years to
the 30 people
and then since the alex token has gone
up in value
uh i've done like other experiments
since
an exclusive content to benefit my
community
got it and so the idea here is um people
can buy the tokens right there was a
token sale but can they also
buy them elsewhere in order to get uh
part of the tokens that you didn't sell
to those original
investors who put up 30 or 20 thousand
dollars yes
so 10 was reserved for those and put the
immense majority
uh which doesn't have any claim on
income or whatever and it's used as a
utility for my community
um are on uni swap right now because uni
swap
is permissionless and you know you've
got uh bradley from raw on board which
is the creator of my social token
and he always does that the team
actually stakes
a bit of heath to create some initial
liquidity for my token
got it and so when somebody goes and
buys to alex token today
uh because they weren't part of the
token sale they don't get a claim on
your income right only those investors
do what do i get
in exchange for uh for buying alex token
so you get tons of things so first
you get access to my telegram group only
group chat
um we have like a bot that actually
checks if you have enough alex and kicks
you out if you
sell the tokens uh also a newsletter so
that's the two like exclusive content to
get updated with my life
and because i have a commitment that i
will continue experience with the token
that's informal with my community uh if
i get more popular
which is actually a purpose incentive
because successful is different from
popular
if i get more popular the token should
have more fans buying into it for the
expense that i'm doing
and potentially uh could go up anyway so
um other than this i've done control my
life
which is a quite clickbait title for
personal token voting and so austin
griffis a very famous ethereum developer
uh did this erc20 voting thing and
basically
people could stake on my daily habit in
july
and so there was like slowly living off
bitcoin or waking up at six a.m
or running off five miles which i've
done and this voted
this vote won and the fourth one i don't
remember but i think it's like go vegan
and it's funny like a million tokens
were voted there's only four million
circulating right now which is such a
huge participation rate
compared to many like other
organizations in the space so that was
very funny to see
and so what you basically did was you
said hey there's four things that i may
do this month
if you're a token holder you get a vote
and you're literally going to
control my life right you're going to
basically the crowd's going to decide
what i do
exactly yeah and so this happened over a
week
and at the end uh running five miles
uh one and so to prove myself
on my alex only telegram group chat
i've gone on to publish trava uh like
runs every single day i mean five days a
week
for the whole month of july running five
kilometers and that was that was very
fun
got it and so extrapolate this out right
is
uh you're the first person to kind of do
a lot of these things
uh i think again a lot of people look at
it and they say uh that's kind of an
experiment
um but why are you doing this and then
how do you think that this
uh evolves over time like what does this
look like in the study state is every
human walking around with their own
token
uh and we're all controlling each
other's lives or how does that play
so there's so many different things here
um but i think the main one and the one
i'm probably going to use
is that a stake in someone's community
uh is amazing and the fact that people
can support me and have a vehicle to
support me so early on in my life
and i was in europe so i did not benefit
from silicon valley like now i'm
connected to
people in the bay area and very young
you know they can get like a hundred
thousand dollars
from wealthy people very young to
optimize their impacts
and so i did not get that i was born in
paris and so for me it's like a whole
new vehicle
uh way better than student loans weber
than other alternatives of funding
uh then you know it exists today so i'm
creating this whole new different path
it's clunky because i'm never i'm like
the only one there pretty much now
there's more people there's around 10 of
us i think
um and so yeah creating my own path to a
little bit of funding but also
the fact that i'm piloting this also got
me some attention connections
and so so far it's not my full-time
thing like i'm still a founder building
startups
and i've actually got a personal token
manager like a month ago which is super
weird like 20 20 jobs
um but uh yeah i'm just keeping this
aside thing because it really interests
people
and i love experimenting what is a po a
personal token manager
so that person is cooper tully and he is
a talent manager for
artists in los angeles but he also is
one of the
biggest contributors to the defiant
which is a new source for ethereum info
and so mixing those two is literally
being my agent
my agent especially as personal token
people probably in the future will be
athletes
or uh entrepreneurs artists and so this
is the kind of same
vibe where you know if i have some otc
deals where people want to buy my token
in bulk
other than uni swap for voting in my
experiment he could handle the deals
or he could suggest some experiments and
so he has
other people under his arm and he just
started this like a month ago
which for me is fascinating and yeah i'm
super glad to be part of it and at the
same time
just like an artist can focus on music
whilst the manager does all the business
stuff
same for me i can focus on my startup
and he's like experimenting with my
token on the side
got it and so uh you're young how old
are you
i just done 24. i was playing the young
card so long
but now it's like yeah listen as
somebody who's 32 and still gets called
young 24 you've got a long way to go
before everybody says that you're not
young
uh talk to me a little bit about
uh where does this drive and the
ambition
come from in terms of you've met a lot
of people you've built a great network
you've tinkered with a lot of technology
uh and you're only 24 years old like
most 24 year olds are trying to figure
out how to get drunk on the weekend like
why are you doing this
i'm doing this because uh there was like
a bug in the matrix where
at like 13 i got so fascinated by steve
jobs
and steve jobs is the best especially
compared to my background where i'm not
that technical
and steve jobs is someone that's pretty
much you know product and marketing
as a tech person uh and this is what i'm
driving for today and
i seem to be doing well at both of those
so far
uh and crypto is also the best field to
enter because the level of talent
isn't still world class i think silicon
valley dismisses crypto for now
which is healthy for young entrepreneurs
like me to kind of like sharpen the
knife
in the meantime uh so it's like yeah so
basically initially steve jobs i'm just
so fascinated for me apple is the best
brand in the world
and they actually are anyway by market
cap right so yeah
got it and and so as you think about
these personalized tokens these
community tokens
you mentioned a little bit uh you know
you're a young guy who
who's kind of sharpening the blade right
or kind of at the tip of the spear of
this
but when you pull that back it sounds
like you think that every musician
every entrepreneur every athlete and
pretty much anyone in the spotlight is
going to have one of these
is that fair i think so just like you
know justin cann which is the founder of
twitch uh was the weirdo uh streaming
himself
and then he created a billion dollar
platform called twitch uh i think right
now i'm that weirdo
uh monetizing myself but i think every
single creator of every type even
politicians
i can see in the future could rally
their community
and that would be awesome right i think
you know artists
uh usually thank fans uh you know by
saying i will be nothing without you
thank you so much for being there my day
ones etc
but they never thank them financially
and i think uh it's long overdue that we
do that
got it and so as that plays out is this
something where the token
uh structures are like inflationary you
can create more tokens is it something
where there's just a
a preset kind of artificial cap
somewhere like a bitcoin like how do you
think about that token structure
uh especially when you're starting out
and you've got 30 investors but
if you were to become you know the next
drake or the next lebron james
you then could have the potential of
millions and millions of people wanting
access to this that makes sense so right
now uh the model that roll does
with me and all the other tokenized
people is a 10 million fixed cap
that's not going gonna be inflated uh
and it took investing mechanism
of 200 000 every single month and so i
kind of cheated on it like we unlocked a
million tokens for
like the investor stuff because that's
uh special but it's
like still that way and for me it's
great fix supply i can understand
because it's only my early fans and
you know if i get super famous later
does everyone want
to be a token holder of myself maybe not
uh maybe more the super fans so that's
fine it's fixed supply
to kind of create some scarcity um and
then the vesting is great in my opinion
because as i grow in popularity the
token gets a bit more liquid and if it
was all at once
it would not be as exciting and now we
can see growth
in all segments so that's great got it
and is the thought process that
uh these people will stop looking for
dollars or
or uh whatever the fiat currency is and
they'll just want the
appreciation of their token or is it
something where they coexist so hey i
still want the cash flow but then i also
want the the token to appreciate in
price too
i think it will coexist uh but i do
think that if you're a huge fan of
someone
you would love to get as near that
tokens because
surely all of their products and
services will be linked at least maybe
as a like loyalty discount scheme
uh but of course i think uh fiat
denomination at least
is here to stay it's just so simple yeah
and given what you've done already
you've been doing this for what six
months give or take
uh what are the biggest surprises or the
things that if you could go back you
wouldn't do
uh biggest surprises uh so yeah people
go into two categories
either they're like oh my god you're
going to lose control of your life this
is
undeterred servitude uh you're going to
be
uh like enslaved by your shareholders
and this is the worst like you have no
control
and i'm like well no i do have control
like this is an experiment like the
control my life thing was clickbait
because i'm good at marketing but it's
not actually controlling my life
uh and then the second thing is both
saying you have too much control
this is 2017 ico you are scam you're
gonna run off with the money etc
and so these two points that are
negative towards
this experiment kind of contradicts
themselves um
so it's nice because it feels like i'm
still at the middle right now
but i can't see both of the sides going
wrong and i think
i don't have any regrets but i do have
some potential
things to advise future tokens and
future personal tokens
which is maybe have some recourse have
some trustless
you know uh quote-unquote um ways
to make sure you don't rip off the
community i have
i haven't done it personally uh because
it was so early on but i think we're
gonna learn as a space
and so far i am tourist worthy you know
i didn't do any exit scam
i'm a great person so far so
it's okay and i'm actually willing to
enforce myself
some rules maybe you know i don't know
maybe like a buy-back program in the
future
or something like this uh and or add
recourse retractively
so i'm really open to uh keep security
high
and like keep every investor safe right
this is a playground
this is not even investors to be honest
it's not like shareholders of my
community
uh so when you say that you're a good
person so far are you planning to not be
a good person in the future
yeah no but like i advertise like you
know even for my token sale or anything
like i can technically run away with the
money this is
you know not trust less uh you know it's
the opposite of the trustless protocols
in d5 for instance
uh where it's like set up on ethereum uh
this is just a person that you have to
trust but at least my repetition is on
the line
and most of my career has been on that
reputation so i have
really no incentive to run away but i
just wanted to let know people that
i could still turn bad but of course i
won't it makes
no sense but i just want to be honest
got it
and then in terms of um you're giving
a percentage of your income i think it's
15 for three years
how do if i'm one of those uh uh token
holders that
get that income share how do i know how
much money you made
right so uh we discussed this a lot
and i won't give my tax return
and people will have to believe what i
made
um and so i basically like i did it for
the first time last month because it was
the first quarter
and i described all my payments i've
gone
through um and yeah
that's it like i don't know there was no
there's no trustless way again
and even then i could perhaps like fake
my tax return like i think it's really
based on trust
and if you don't trust me or trust that
i will do good you probably should stay
away from this
uh why not give the tax return i think
most people would say like oh that would
be the easiest way to prove it is it
just because it's got sensitive
information or what's the
thought process to not share that yeah
maybe i'll do it in the future it's just
that
i haven't filed a tax chat for next year
so it was by a quarter so like i kind of
had to do
gross income which is actually more
money for the shareholders anyway
got it and um in terms of uh
those payments and stuff are you
publishing that for
anyone in the world to see and just the
people who hold the tokens get it or is
that information that's just shared with
the token holders like how do you think
about
i guess uh like the transparency and uh
information sharing versus income
sharing
so um the income sharing is public on
the ethereum blockchain
uh i haven't advertised it i think i've
said it on twitter like you know the
airdrop has happened etc maybe i put the
link
but i didn't want to say the amount that
i've made too loud
i have a newsletter that people have to
pay alex for to access it where i
disclose it even if you're not one of
the investors
so if you want to go that route that's
fine but i probably
i don't want to reveal financial
information too publicly on twitter
um and yeah i'm i think people if people
can dig they can see
but actually it's quite hidden because
it's in the currency
that's not actually picked from one uh
first we thought usdc or a double coin
but now it's in
alex lp tokens on the knees web so like
people operating liquidity that's how
they pay me
so it's actually a very funny way
because although it's public it's quite
hard to reverse engineer how much i made
which i find funny uh but people can if
they uh you know
book miles later got it um
and then in terms of uh how this evolves
over time
do you think that people will have to uh
kind of diverge from the oh just trust
me model
to something that's like on chain cash
flow or
some other model uh where people say no
i want to be able to verify what your
income is
either for you or for like a big you
know athlete musician whatever
yeah for sure i think and we saw spencer
and woody i think he closed this sale so
he's a
nba uh player that took an isis contract
he's the first one he got some pushback
from the nba but i think he ended up
doing it
um i think yeah i think you know i
haven't done this properly because
this was the first time with a very tiny
reasonable amount but i think
uh i could see some regulations
around it and making it like the kind of
news investment the new y combinator
i can totally see that in action and
there will be some rules and
enforcements
to protect the shareholders what's the
craziest thing that somebody's asked
you or the craziest uh pushback that
you've gotten
like listen and for those that are
listening uh
i'm fascinated by this uh because i
can't tell
how much of this is like complete
[ __ ] this is gonna go like you know
it's gonna
fall off a cliff and then you're gonna
call me one day and be like dude that
was a fun experiment but like it didn't
work at all
versus uh like there is this like
small glimmer that i see where people
have
uh kind of income sharing via like
tokenization or something like that now
what platform does it get built on
what's the currency like there's so many
questions as to like how it actually
gets implemented
but the idea of like just a simple uh
on-chain
cash flow but that's interesting right
right and so how do you kind of start to
incorporate that okay well if then
you can get access to that information
it's easier to
uh maybe there's not true corporations
right like i know that there's companies
in i think both bitcoin and
ethereum uh kind of communities that say
look we're not gonna go with the
traditional legal structure instead
we're gonna do everything on chain and
like your ownership is basically held
on chain and therefore you have a claim
on cash flows and things like that
this feels very similar to that right
right right
well first of all yeah let me defend
personal tokens
because i don't think it's i don't think
it's [ __ ] at all uh you know
kickstarter works
uh kickstarter is a model to invest in
people before they achieve their
potential
uh isa with them that school education
for software engineers
really work and so we know that if we
add like
the capitalism speculation and facial
aspect that crypto brings
so easily it would be great because it
would attract more revenue
for creators which are typically a
persona that doesn't make enough money
and
is struggling to monetize right like
people spend hours
listening to podcasts do podcasters
really get paid for the amount of time
people consume
versus netflix or music and even netflix
on music
are quite on the played so i think it
would be huge to have more monetization
for all types of creators athletes
entrepreneurs politicians
um and so that's that's for my defense
uh
all right hold on hold on hold on before
you continue okay so uh
i will buy most of that argument
but what does that look like let's say
that uh let's take a musician and an
athlete so for lebron james and then
let's say for drake
right is this something where uh they
create
tokens they uh once they're already a
star
they then have like a token sale ico
whatever you know whatever
the latest uh you know kind of
vocabulary is for this
uh but they basically sell the tokens
into the market they hold some back
maybe there's investing maybe there's
not and then they create like an economy
or an ecosystem where you can only use
the lebron james token to
go to his games or buy things in his
store or attend you know maybe movies he
produces or stuff like that
or is it something that's more of like a
loyalty point
so it's within this closed ecosystem but
all you can really do is maybe
win like a cool experience or do
something like that like how do you see
it actually
uh in the steady state somebody like
lebron james or
drake using this stuff so i think it can
be either
so either the revenue income or the
loyalty discount
and maybe the latter is gonna be easier
legally right
because it's just you know 15 off my
merch
as drake then you know the superstars i
don't think
unless the first one i think you know
the first one will have a premium
because it is the first one
that is a superstar doing it but i think
long term
the best people to uh that should do a
personal token should be
b-list celebrities that have potential
to go a-list
and so that way the more potential is
the more
gains for the people who want to invest
in that token
got it and is the thought process that
uh
literally you're like buying a rising
star right like similar similar to
buying a stock that
is poised to break out you're basically
being able to quote
invest in the person before they break
out yeah
exactly that's how i see it because the
person has potential
you invest in it so you got the early
fans now and the speculators who
objectively think
that the star is going to arise so
that's just momentization
and that's great i think crypto is about
making everything liquid
and this is a fun step towards it you're
either out of your mind or or you're
dead
and look and i think there's a lot of
people who will hear me talking about
this stuff right in the back why are you
even talking about it
and what's interesting to me is uh
the more that you get into like hey i
have a currency like look at this thing
that you can use to pay me and do all
that kind of stuff like and probably not
have sold on that
the idea that uh this is just the next
iteration from kickstarter to isas to
you know tokenization of this person and
basically
um you know what's the difference
between somebody's uh
parents giving them a loan right versus
them using this as a way to
raise capital right it's just it's a new
capital markets mechanism
for an individual uh there's probably
all kinds of legal things that need to
be figured out but in terms of like that
as a use case
uh you can see the use cases there it's
just how does it actually get
implemented that probably determines
whether it's successful or not
yeah for sure um we'll see in the future
to be honest yeah like we can't know
if it's ridiculous or not but i tend to
think the most ridiculous ideas
actually end up being trillion dollar
companies
look that's why i'm saying you're either
out of your mind or you're going to be
right
yes but that's the good part it's like
it's very rare to find ideas
that look really really dumb and weird
but at the same time it's like
well i'm not sure if it's going to
nothing
or to like a massive world-changing
thing
i uh i think that you also
are uh the sense i get from you and you
tell me if i'm right or wrong
you either think that this is gonna end
up being very kind of foolish
and a toy or this is gonna end up being
a trillion dollar thing right like i
like i think you have a kind of a binary
outcome
uh in terms of how this plays out or am
i wrong on that oh yeah for sure i think
the biggest thing usually started as
toy and bitcoin had the same treatment
right so
and now it's not a toy anymore all right
that's fair we're on the same page
because of all the things that you're
doing uh you've been building a bunch
on ethereum uh two questions one is just
how much of this are you building versus
your leveraging
tools and uh platforms that other people
have built and then we'll get into
talking kind of bitcoin and ethereum but
just
help people understand like how much of
this is reliant on you doing it
versus you're able to leverage other
things that are built and they could go
do it if they wanted
right so uh first since i'm not very
technical of course i know basics of
coding to be in the space
but um if doing means coding
no i haven't coded any of my stuff a
little bit controlled my life which is
one of my experiments with the alex
token
uh i've done some front end but that's
like very little work
uh no i think the huge part about this
serum is composability
meaning that people build a smart
contract you can build on top of it and
so for instance i can give an example so
rocket is a landing platform that take
nft which is unique items
on ethereum and so i've taken like the
dao
governance so like the way people can
decide how to give loans to people like
i raise 50 000
for those lenders um then give out nft
and it's like a transaction to like a
multi-sig that
holds nft and so i've used all the tools
available to me on ethereum
and there's so much positive some
experiments to be done
uh there's not enough people i mean
there's so many builders coming to
ethereum
but the space is still so vague like i
remember one of my marketing technique
is like to say this is the world's first
ever like i said this is the world's
first ever domain name as a collateral
or the world's first ever crypto art
piece as a collateral like we took josie
bernini she's a famous ethereum artist
and we gave a loan against it because we
knew it would be valuable long term
in our opinion and so yeah you know
uh building on top of others but it's
still
the very first uh you know foundation
anyway i think right now ethereum is a
bunch of apis
and we need the front end for the end
user and that's not being
built right now but it will in the
future
all right then you keep saying this uh
bitcoin is to ethereum as email is to
the internet what the hell does that
mean
well it's because you know email was the
first
form of data on the internet and it was
the like one of the best and we still
use it and email is never going anywhere
uh there's superhuman and other
companies doing some niches but mostly
it's like a free service and it's
really awesome that it's decentralized
and then there's the internet which is
billions of ways to see data and i see
the same thing with value right so
bitcoin is
one kind of value and that's great and
it's not going away
because of its brilliant marketing and
branding
but ethereum which has a less good
marketing in its name
but the platform will speak for itself
because billions of smart contracts
will then become startups which will
become extremely successful
and i think right now it's unsuitable at
this point they reach escape velocity
and even if some other competing
blockchain builds on top of it
it will be a layer two solution uh so
i'm extremely bullish on ethereum
and the fact that you can create so many
different sources of bitcoin
for each flavor that you want whether
it's lending insurance borrowing
any kind of usage of value i think for
me it's really revolutionary
so there's a bunch of people who listen
to this that are into bitcoin there's a
bunch of people who listen to this that
are into ethereum
uh i will put you on the spot what are
the pros and cons of bitcoin
first how do you look at bitcoin what do
you say hey these are the good things
but and then these are the bad things
probably bitcoin has a regulatory edge
because
i guess you know all the politicians etc
are going to look at bitcoin first
before ethereum
um the cons it's that it's a bit boring
like you know there's nothing happening
there's like a halving every four years
or something
like i want exciting stuff to build on i
want to be useful like how can i be
useful
in bitcoin besides being an influencer
i'm not sure how can i
do anything and so ethereum you can
build so much stuff
it's so impressive it's like this is the
future this is the internet this
is where uh like the next innovations
happen this is where the next superstars
are born
uh so of course ethereum any day
you know that you're trolling and you're
laughing without which i respect
it's not i'm not trolling like ethereum
is so
amazing as a platform and you know why
okay hold on hold on we don't trade gold
every day but
we use the internet every day and so we
will maybe have some bitcoin it will be
like
you know the family treasury if like
your dad is a bitcoin
you know old addict but like
every single person is going to have
lending solution based on
ethereum why is it going to be based on
ethereum
well i mean of course like the like if
tomorrow
data saves otherwise i will jump off
ethereum but right now the data
is like obvious it's everywhere it's
just working so well
and ethereum 2.0 is not even live layer
2 is not even live
so is it is ethereum 2.0 ever going to
launch
well i'm bearish on the timeline maybe
it won't be this year as
some people say phase zero will but it's
gonna happen it's
some of the smartest engineers in the
world working on this
like if it's not them then who
okay uh well it could just be nobody
right and they could just never launch
i i i tend to think that it will launch
at some point i'm with you on that
timeline is always uh the hard part
for everything in uh bitcoin ethereum
crypto everything right so not just them
um in terms of ethereum what are the
pros and cons
so the pros of the theorem is that it's
the next
uh single biggest financial
infrastructure of the universe
and then the cons is that it's still
working progress it's still
slow expensive and not scalable
and the ux still sucks so there's tons
to
improve but the fact that despite all of
its flaws
it's growing so much especially g5 right
now so
finance under all forms including
tokenized bitcoin
that's going very fast makes it
really really uh impressive and
something to follow so
this is just my opinion like i i grew up
like listening to your podcast when i
started getting into crypto
and then i slowly started saying like oh
uh
anthony is a bit too much into bitcoin
yeah
listen we've invested in a lot of things
that build on top of uh ethereum and are
uh related to the defy stuff right so i
i don't know why people think that uh
i'm necessarily a maximalist as much as
i think i'm more of a realist in terms
of
uh there's just a lot of
and actually react to this right so what
do you think about this my whole
position on the
uh ethereum and ether world is that
there's a lot of technology being built
but there's not a lot of products being
built
and what i mean by that is everyone is
saying like oh look at this shiny thing
that i made it do
and when you show a bunch of other
technical people or people who are like
really in the weeds
like oh that's awesome but then if you
go and you try to get any mainstream
user to use
i would argue almost any d5 product
there's nobody outside of like that
small technical audience who could
figure out how to use it has an interest
in using it etc
so it's still to me um very kind of uh
uh technology being built not
necessarily like user-friendly products
whereas i think bitcoin was like that at
some point
right so there was a point where you
know if you it be even before mount gox
or even mount gox like there was just
you know not the average joe was going
to buy bitcoin right it was always
people kind of on the fringes and super
technical all that kind of stuff
but eventually there was products built
that now make it really easy
right and so the thought process is at
some point probably
and hopefully for for the d5 community
and ethereum and all that you get the
products built
it's just that we're not there yet right
so agree or disagree with that
oh yeah completely agree with that i
would just disagree on the bitcoin part
i don't see any product built on bitcoin
maybe lowly which is you know
cash back on bitcoin great company but
apart from cash back on bitcoin there is
no product
none of my friends know how to buy
bitcoin a part of the
in revolut which is already like a quite
next-gen fintech
startup um but yeah i do agree like i
think
d5 six months ago was not even one
billion dollar locked
so that's ridiculously tiny and so yeah
like i'm not saying
ethereum is nowhere near yet in terms of
products
there's some things going on with
foundation and zora which make the
design very pretty
for artists to tokenize and it's
actually quite adjacent to personal
tokens
but apart from those yeah all the
lending platform is really hard and
that's actually what i'm
trying to focus on in my next startup
which will try to help bring consumers
but
we're all trying to do this and it's
really hard and maybe the hard
answer is as long as we don't have eth2
it's just not scalable and it's like for
nerds and it's the netscape of the
internet
um you are of the belief that silicon
valley has kind of dismissed crypto
explain that
oh yeah for sure but this is again just
like my last
argument uh defy is just way too tiny
for silicon valley to care
uh and so this is why and so bitcoin is
probably dismissed as you know it's just
for people who hate governments and
super libertarian
and it's not the end consumer and
ethereum
is extremely tiny but right now it's
growing at the magnificent pace
so it's it went from i think 100 million
last year
to i think right now it's like 10
billion 15 billion i can't even keep
count but there was this famous video of
shamat that you go on in your podcast
the billionaire
um he said he didn't know about defy and
it's funny because i think it's gonna
become a household name probably next
year
maybe not a household name because it's
still a geeky term decentralized but i
think some defy products
will uh cross the chasm very soon and so
the reason why silicon valley
dismisses it is simply because yeah the
the value being exchanged and locked
is ridiculous compared to bitcoin which
is still ridiculous competition finance
but the rate at which it's growing
is enormous just like jeff bezos i think
he said in the 90s uh
i started amazon where the internet was
kind of dead but it was growing
at 19 000 percent a year and we
are at this time ether is growing at 19
000 percent a year
or something maybe i'm a writing but
it's growing really fast
and this is the reason why it should not
be dismissed and
some amazing maybe next fang companies
are going to be built do you want to
know the number one thing i think that
uh the ethereum and d5 community could
do to
accelerate all of that yeah please do
is is to say uh bitcoin is the first d5
application
right well it's not really uh bitcoin
has to be costly by banks and things
that you don't control trustlessly
no bitcoin is the only thing that is
trust
uh trustless right in terms of on
ethereum
it's not encouraged to run a full node
on bitcoin it is and from a custody
standpoint
bitcoin is much more secure much more
decentralized
right so i think the reason why i say
that uh the defined ethereum community
saying that what it does is it actually
allows them to draft off of the market
acceptance of bitcoin
right there's no uh there's no confusion
or uh lack of interest when it comes to
crypto almost everyone talks about
bitcoin right in terms of the people who
aren't like the hardcore crypto
enthusiast and so what i think is rather
than trying to say hey we're different
what you really want to do is you want
to basically say no look
we're just like bitcoin and we're
smaller we're going to grow to be that
size one day too
right because that would represent from
a market cap standpoint i think what
ether is like one-tenth the market cap
of bitcoin
yeah but it's gonna flip it is it
yeah of course like the internet flipped
gold
ages ago and i mean yeah i just
it's inevitable to me and i don't know
but hold on did the internet flip the
global money supply no but that's also
an ethereum task
uh bitcoin is not globally supplied if
bitcoin is digital gold
why is it not money um it's not money
because you can't spend it every day so
that's
medium of exchange is that a requirement
for your definition of money
but if sorry so i'm going to give you an
economics lesson ready
if you go down this path bitcoin is used
how much more than ethereum every day or
ether every day
uh i think the ethereum fees flipped the
bitcoin fees and actually i think uni
swap now
equals bitcoin so ethereum knowledge is
equally decentralized no no no no
no bitcoin as well hold up hold on not
exchange volume we're not talking about
exchange volume
we're talking about actual on-chain
transaction volumes
not trading right yeah but the fees the
gas fees actually
outpace bitcoin for uni swap which is
just one protocol
on ethereum and the crazy part is that
uh you know bitcoin wants to rely on
block space value
but ethereum has more expensive block
space value
just imagine the price of block space
value that's going to be much more
than bitcoin when isom flips bitcoin are
you making the argument that more people
use ether than bitcoin right now
uh maybe not but
i don't i don't have maybe you have one
statistic that would like
be against me but so if you look at
if you go and you use do you adjusted
on-chain
every day i just don't understand like
you store bitcoin i guess
well hold on hold on a second so there's
two pieces first of all
a store of value right holding on to it
is a use case
right same with ether right if ether
wants to be a store value and a medium
of exchange holding it is a use case
fair
right yeah but the second piece is the
adjusted on chain transaction volume so
if you take out all the exchanges and
and anything going in and out of
exchange uh wallets all that kind of
stuff so right
i think it's coinmetrix has this stack
and you look at
bitcoin's transaction volume on chain
with all that removed it's called the
adjusted on chain transaction volume it
is more
than the amount of volume that's done on
paypal venmo
or apple pay last year right so 2019
more people used
the bitcoin network for transaction
volume that was
not going in and out of exchanges or
using on exchanges but actual
some sort of transaction now what it is
we don't know right same with ether like
for a lot of the the
transactions we don't actually know what
are people sending it for
right but we do know that they're
sending it and so i think that the
um the the argument here and this is
kind of my point is like
making an argument that ether is used
more than bitcoin i think is
one data disproves that but also too is
rather than
um trying to uh um
make the flipping argument instead what
ends up happening is ether
and ethereum is used for something
completely different right and and
to your point like there's things that
people can do with ethereum that you
can't do with bitcoin
now people in the bitcoin community i
think would argue like that's a good
that's a good thing right and then
there's a reason why that's true i think
people in the ethereum community would
argue
no the fact that it does something
different is a good thing and you know
we should continue to double down
so my whole thing's always been like
both communities and products just
double down on what
they do best right rather than you know
bitcoin try to be uh the next ico
platform or capital markets
type platform or ethereum and ether try
to be
money right it's just like double down
on what you're good at
and then that's what ends up actually
you know providing 90 plus percent of
the value of that community in that
piece of technology
sure yeah i mean the biggest pie is the
buy left to
eat right so uh bitcoin is still quite
tidy compared to the entire traditional
course finance system
uh and maybe your data disproves that uh
ethereum uh is more valuable and more
like often transacted
uh in volume uh but i don't care about
today's data i think
in the next few years this is difficult
to happen because just because consumers
land they exchange stable coins um
they borrow they insure they stake they
bet
they play like they do so many things
and in bitcoin it's like they hold
so i think the data is going to disprove
uh your point
very very soon how much uh stu
how much value is locked in d5 right now
do you know
i think something like 15 billion
dollars and it was
15 one five yeah one five yeah it's in
time
last year it was 800 million i think uh
it's occurring
was it earlier this year it broke a
billion i think i think so yeah it's
insane the growth i think we're going to
end the year with like 50 billion locked
in d5 that would be fair
but but the the thing i always wonder uh
and i don't know if you know this answer
or not
uh and so whoever's listening to this if
you can figure this out uh tweeted both
of us
is how much of that is what i call like
net new capital inflow
so i took dollars or i took bitcoin and
like and put it in
versus uh you and i create a token
and then we stake it somewhere right and
like that's not technically net new
capital inflow that's like
we created you know half a billion
dollars of market cap and now that
counts towards that metric i don't know
the answer
uh but that would be one of the
questions of like what's the net new
capital inflow so when it goes from a
billion to 15
is that literally 14 billion dollars
flowing in right
ether's market cap i think is like 25
billion
if i uh remember correctly and so like
it's what is it billion 50 yeah yeah
okay yeah so it's it's tens of billions
right so like
14 billion dollars of capital uh new
capital inflow like
maybe right or maybe it's 50 50 you know
or whatever it is it's just like
to me that feels like a really important
uh
difference because to your point like
there's ether
and then there's the stable coins and
there's all these other things built on
top of ethereum and so how you count all
that stuff
i think illuminates not only what is the
overall growth of the ecosystem but also
um what are the things that are actually
driving the growth right because my
guess is let's say that that is
you know 14 billion dollars of growth
there's probably two or three things
where
you know 90 of the growth happens and
then everything else is kind of
maybe trending slightly upwards but
really it's you know
unit swap or something like that that's
driving most of the growth right
well first of all i think d5 pulse which
tracks the value locked in d5 actually
accounts for this
but yeah like i think uh platforms like
token daily
and other blogs have said you know this
might be recycling the same old money
over and over
with new protocols and perhaps but in
each bull cycle
it starts with a group of degenerate
people um
you know like the core group and then
because of the excitement it brings more
money from outside of that see the
growth
so i think definitely we are very early
in this pool cycle
as of august 2020 but i'm sure that
uh next year there will be retail and
consumers going on for those new
strategies of investments that are way
healthier by the way than the ico in
2017 so i'm super proud of this
absolutely uh before we do the rapid
fire which i know you're you're
ready to talk about some aliens uh i uh
help me understand how do you think of
portfolio construction in terms of
do you own bitcoin do you own ether you
obviously own alex tokens like like how
do you think about
um kind of your portfolio
uh don't tell me amounts but just like
percentage-wise
um do you own things other than bitcoin
and ether and alex like like help me
understand that
so i dumped all my bitcoin for
ethereum last year or something and now
like you you talk to the least
wise investor ever 99
of my net worth no sorry uh maybe like
90
of my net worth is in uh ether
uh long ether on on the maker volts and
it's insured by nexus mutual which is an
insurance solution
on ethereum and that's basically most of
my net worth and then of course i have
alex but i don't really count alex of my
net worth
because i don't think i will sell alex
on the market that's
quite unethical right now especially as
the market is illiquid
so yeah like 90 plus of my liquid
uh net worth is long east got it and
uh so you sold all your bitcoin and then
you don't own anything else in terms of
uh like other major crypto assets that
people i don't know so
i own also other d5 protocols tokens
um whether like for marketing campaigns
or
for uh like the sd5 which is like a
basket of all the default coins because
i think you know like the less liquid
token is and the better it is the higher
the uh returns right so that's why
probably ethereum is gonna
have a better bull run than bitcoin
other than having the actual use case
which will be like the device stuff
that bitcoin doesn't have so uh yeah the
less liquid it is like d5 protocols i
think are going to go like
100x or something at least the great
ones
i love i love your enthusiasm
and the fact is i know that you that
you're enjoying this just as much as i
am so that makes me happy yeah
um all right so uh last two questions
uh what's the most important book that
you've ever read um
i think steve jobs the biography
because he's like my idol like yeah
what would you ask steve jobs if you go
to dinner with him
i don't that's so yeah i would love to
like
but i don't think i think uh you know
the young makes
room for the new wait the old next room
for the young
and so that's fine if i'd ever meet him
but i would love to
well you can't meet him he's dead yeah
exactly so that's why it's like i
am i am relief because it's fine that's
like how time passes
and i think that's what the wisdom he
wanted to share as well which is like
i don't need steve jobs uh he inspired
me and that's great and now it's my turn
uh to have an impact and to inspire
people all right
aliens believer or non-believer uh
yeah i guess believers statistically
like most people
but then i read max denmark
livestream.oh which argues that
um we might be alone if we consider like
the
um like distancible universe like
uh like the universe that you can go to
and it's just impossible because it's
just so vast
that there probably are some aliens but
that's just so far away
and we would need either civilization to
be at the speed of light
and going towards us full speed uh
we have a chance to meet uh aliens so i
don't think probably they are real but
we probably won't meet them because
we are nothing in the realm of time
right so
that's why uh yeah aliens exist we might
never meet them
i actually think that's the most
realistic uh perspective is they
definitely exist
and there's some other life form out
there but uh
right so we can expect anything from 20
20 even aliens
absolutely all right you could ask me
one question what uh what question you
have for me
so would you tokenize yourself or when
are you going
all in on ethereum so i thought you were
going to ask me if i would buy some of
your alex tokens
i thought that's where what you were
yeah can you buy alex please
no i cannot
uh so here's the way that i think about
this um i would not tokenize myself
uh for a whole host of reasons from
right
uh i'm an american citizen uh my
i just have a lot of complexity already
in terms of investments and all that
kind of stuff
uh and that would just like i can
imagine sitting down with an accountant
and trying to have this conversation
they would just lock you out of the room
um
but the uh the thing that i am
interested in
um is i love the collectibles market
i think that's super interesting um
especially when you get digital versions
versus the analog versions right um i'm
shocked
that given the popularity of like the
sports trading card world
uh that there hasn't been like more you
know how do we do digital trading cards
all that kind of stuff
um then the other thing i would say is
uh
i think that um the whole idea of like
tokenizing companies in a way to use
technology to have a claim on the cash
flow
right so um i think it's base camp
maybe is the company that it's like an
llc and the two founders
uh they let bezos buy into it and he
owns like 10 or something
and so like at the end of every quarter
or every year or whatever they just like
distribute cash
right and so like to me it just feels
like
as much as the last couple of decades
has driven like complexity and financial
engineering and capital markets and like
all that kind of stuff
this technology just like simplifies
things against and starts to automate
uh so what you end up doing is like when
you reduce
accounting frauds to you end up actually
having a much bigger incentive for
people from an equity ownership
standpoint
uh and then three is it becomes really
interesting when now all of a sudden
there's no difference in in somebody in
the united states in europe
in southeast asia in south america or on
the continent of africa
everyone with an internet connection is
quote unquote equal right in terms of
their ability to participate in
financial services and ownership of
uh assets things like that and so i
think that's just one of these like
inflection points in human history
that ends up saying wait a second uh if
now i can basically empower people if i
can teach them to fish right rather than
give them the fish
what are humans capable of like who the
hell would have thought that you know a
24 year old sitting in europe was going
to go and tokenize himself
like nobody right and so it's just like
like there's so much more that will
happen
uh some of it will be good some of it
will be bad uh you know literally some
would be [ __ ] coins and some of it will
be you know real value but
i think that's kind of the encouragement
of innovation and experimentation drives
a lot of this stuff
and so like you know you definitely fall
in the category of like either you're a
genius or you're absolutely lost your
mind
um but i think that like you're
comfortable living
in that spectrum right and the world
needs people
like you and others like you to go try
some of this stuff and like
either you're gonna figure it out or
you're not right but like if you're
comfortable doing that and it's
important to you then like
knock yourself out right yeah thank you
and uh
of course yeah you might not need a
personal token uh
because maybe you're not young enough or
maybe
or not just that because you're already
like a list in your industry
and you will go with the bull market and
you already you know
master monetization with your newsletter
and everything and so you might not need
that extra boost
that you know emerging creators needs so
i really get that
yeah and but do you have any ethereum no
okay can i give you something no
no listen here here's uh i mean i talked
about some million times in the podcast
but basically
my whole thought process is uh
it's not just a financial uh evaluation
for me
right and so if you think of in a
financial market like this is one thing
that i think
uh the bitcoin community uh doesn't talk
about a lot but i do think is
intellectually honest so
if you look at um in a bear in a bull
market
just the uh asset sizes so the largest
assets are likely to actually go down
uh to go up the least right from a
volatility standpoint and the smallest
market cap ones when in a bull market
should go up even more
right well same thing happens when you
reverse it in the bear market right
is a large cap assets likely to go down
the least a
small cap should go down the most right
now there's always outliers
i get it stopped tweeting at me already
about the fact that like
you know there's some example that
violates that principle but in general
that is true
and so when you bring that to crypto
everything is quote small compared to
the traditional market
right but there still should be some
spectrum in terms of
uh if the largest cap assets go up 2x
then there's going to be a bunch of
these super small assets that go up 8 or
10x
right that's just the law of market caps
and so i think that there's a lot of
people who confuse
you know just the financial returns with
other things
uh and people just have to ask
themselves like are you here just for
the financial return
well then like you should go you know
10x leverage and go buy some
[ __ ] coin that pumps 800 and you know
and you're good right
uh but if you have interest in other
things which i think
uh you do to some degree right and i
think others um
then it's evaluating not just the
financial outcomes but also the the kind
of non-financial impact right
makes sense um fair so are you gonna buy
some bitcoin
no because just it's very fair ethereum
will make the world better
it will enable collectibles that you
like it will enable
uh you know investing in cash flow
earnings that's like the new wave of d5
that's happening right now
and it will dominate the bull market so
i don't see why but i get it like it has
the best branding bitcoin
uh and it is great and i'll probably be
bullish bitcoin
if i was maybe having like a older and
like more wealth
perhaps uh right now i know that if i
maximize
ethereum it will probably go higher than
bitcoin and and still
it's like you know auto rebalancing d5
basket where
it will capture the best protocol that
is on ethereum
so it's a safe bet so i don't like yeah
i don't go
too low in terms of liquidity for my
returns but i'm still
a bit more aggressive than bitcoin but i
think it's gonna pay off
awesome all right where can people find
you on the internet
uh on twitter at alex massenez
m-a-s-m-e-j
um that's it how do you pronounce your
last name so it's a cut from my real
french name which is mas mejong
and i just said mass match on twitter
and i it's weird because people think
i'm polish now but
i'm french um yeah i don't know how to
cut my last name
if anyone has suggestions
[Laughter]
all right man listen i appreciate all
the work you're doing thank you so much
for doing this
and uh i think people will find this
fascinating so we'll have to do it again
in the future as
as you launch other things thank you so
much for watching